it's not my fault i never wanted to be
famous sorry kiddo that's not the way i
remember it disney has done so much to
bring this classic tale to life from tom
hanks's incredible performance with
nothing but a laser pointer the blue
fairy's ethereal costume design to the
legendary robert zemeckis being behind
the lens
number one if anyone can do it tom hanks
can i'm gonna make it look so real that
you're not even gonna it's gonna seem
real to me a big part of his job in this
film was making sure that it looked
believable he was actually talking to
pinocchio not only did he have to make
sure he held eye contact at the
appropriate level but he had to make
sure the expression on his face was
appropriately engaged if it looks like
the live-action actor is looking through
the character and not really looking at
the character then the illusion won't
work
number two tom hanks gives us full
dedication for his role of geppetto he
describes his experience on set as sort
of like just drowning just swimming in
water because they have to do so much in
post the actions they perform on set can
seem a bit chaotic we have to suspend
you upside down which won't look like it
when we have it you have to have a
mouthful of this water then have to spit
it right there every performance in this
film was so incredibly technical it took
a lot of planning to get it just right
now let's do it 17 times till we get it
till we get it naturally right number
three the fairy godmother we still want
to this day robert zemeckis wanted the
blue fairy to be depicted as sweet kind
and yet sensible and practical he wanted
this beautiful mix of equalities in this
character they also wanted her to have a
bit of an edge to her cynthia arrival
was able to keep all of her piercings in
but they replaced the jewelry with
beautiful fairy-like pieces made by the
costume designer it wanted to feel as
fairy-like as we could possibly make it
number four speaking of ethereal and
whimsical we have to talk about cynthia
arrivo's performance of this iconic
disney song when you listen to the song
i want you to believe that i believe
what i'm singing apparently she nailed
it from the very first take robert
zemeckis didn't even need to do a second
but she wanted it to be perfect cynthia
did many retakes after that tweaking
things that she wanted to fix but i
thought they were all magnificent number
five did anyone else's parents do
character voices joseph gordon-levitt
said robert zemeckis gave him some
simple yet game-changing wisdom when it
came to finding his jiminy cricket voice
when you tell your kids stories do you
do voices i was like yeah of course we
are not surprised that joseph
gordon-levitt does in fact get really
into doing the voices when reading his
kids stories okay so just do the jimmy
cricket voice how you do if you were a
dad telling your kids the pinocchio
story well how do crickets the name
jiminy cricket be precise
number six tom hanks and robert zemeckis
go way back robert and tom worked
together most famously on forrest gump
coming back to work with robert on
pinocchio was an opportunity tom didn't
really want to miss out on when he first
heard that robert was thinking about
doing pinocchio he waited for a while
but ultimately had to approach him about
the role of geppetto i asked him are you
really going to direct pinocchio he said
yeah i'm thinking about it i said if you
don't have a gepetto and you can
withstand doing something with me let me
know
number 7. tom hanks is taking notes from
our cats over here not only did he have
to know where pinocchio was in the scene
but he also had to consider all of the
other digital characters sometimes
instead of an off-stage jiminy cricket
talking to him it was just a laser
pointer at one point i had to place in
my head a fish a cat a cricket and a
wooden boy i had to do it all and with
the blue fairy on occasion on our second
or third day there my brain just got
exhausted i said bob can you give me a
minute in order to put all these mental
images in my head and in the right place
number eight benjamin evan ainsworth
channels the 1940s when he was prepping
for his audition he wanted to stay true
to the original pinocchio voice so he
listened a lot to dickie jones as
pinocchio
i'm a real boy
but guess what i'm almost a real boy
following his audition he took his call
back on zoom in a soundproof closet in
which he spent hours prepping his voice
a heptic like couple hours trying to do
this for like a 10 minute zoom number
nine the music is a major part of the
storytelling in addition to the classics
like when you wish upon a star hi diddle
dee dee and i've got no strings there
are four brand new original songs in the
film written by alan silvestri and glenn
ballard when director robert zemeckis
and chris weitz were trying to figure
out when to add new music they decided
to stick to those moments that were the
most emotionally pertinent to the
character's growth what songs do best in
musicals is shore up the emotional
growth of a character or help express
what a character is feeling at any given
moment so that's what we did with the
songs
number 10. you may be surprised by this
one the biggest challenge robert
zemeckis faced when getting the film
done was actually finding the artists to
work on it we have a very serious
shortage of digital artists in the world
and everybody is making movies with
digital effects it's very tough to find
enough people to actually work on your
movies these days the live-action
version of pinocchio has some incredible
performances musical numbers and
costumes bringing it to life it's insane
how much growth the tale can go through
while staying totally true to its
classic origin which was your favorite
new element in this version of pinocchio